hello and welcome to pi data global 2021
my name is rosa i'm going to be the
host of this workshop
so the workshop we're going to have
right now is introduction to distance
metric learning by dor kedam
thor kedan is currently managing a data
science and engineering team at ing bank
in amsterdam
between his tasks we can mention
financial criminal risk mitigation
moneylender risk detection and supports
the analytics team to make the bank more
safely compliant
within nearly two decades of experience
working in i.t big data applications and
data science and door good present an
introduction on distance and metric
learning and as a topic that he has
research and used a lot within a
professional setup okay with a father i
give you all as yours the stage is yours
door and shine
thank you rosa and thanks to everyone
who's uh who's come and attended
maybe before we really get started with
the talk a bit of logistics kind of
position the way that we can interact i
think that
these tutorials are a bit longer and
they're at the zoom meeting rather than
as a webinar so i do encourage a bit
more
engagement
um
the way that i think works well is to
join the the
conversation on slack basically there is
a forum dedicated called introduction to
distance metric learning
join it say hello look at some of the
things that people already posted for
example the link to a notebook is
already there
[Music]
check out the notebook
so during this tutorial we will go both
through this presentation and another
notebook that i prepared my advice to
you is to go through the netbook
somewhere around midway of the talk we
will also go through this together
after a talk i'll also be available in
gevertown you can see my avatar here i
did my best to to mess my other avatar
on slack
um
i will find a seat
also posted on slack and then you can
have that conversation uh follow up
uh i'll still respond on slack channel
so if there were questions that i missed
i'll be able to to pick up or if i
entirely missed all of these channels
you can reach out to me on linkedin just
let me know that you came from this talk
and then we'll be able to cover this
um and i think with that we can we can
get started
um a little bit about the
topic at hand which is an introduction
to distance metric learning
um
a little bit about me
as rosa was mentioning uh data science
engineering manager in ing
um if you're interested really about
what the kind of work that we do in the
group it's really about
topics like outlier detection uh
representation learning graph and entity
resolution as i mentioned before fris
about an hour and a half ago gave a talk
about this topic of entry resolution
do check it out um
and as for me
i my career spent nearly two decades uh
both as software development and data
scientists
sort of machine learning engineer
building etl processes
um and i'll be happy to to converse on
any of those right be it uh topics like
security
banking use cases
machine learning
um and all the way to some of my hobbies
which are board games professional
wrestling
and great cheesecakes in in amsterdam
and if you're interested in joining us
do check out inc.jobs
our topic today
is a bit of business let's say
i think we have about 85 minutes right
now and we will try to cover
a few let's say
key
fundamental topics but also get to the
point where you feel comfortable to try
and apply this in your domain and setup
so we will go through really
from the very basic right what's a
metric a distance function in metric
learning
we will dive into what does it mean to
actually learn a distance it sounds a
bit counterintuitive but we will dive
into this
um we'll
look into related fields like manifold
learning we will learn how do metric
learning loss function look different
than let's say supervised
other supervisor classification
learning loss functions
and we will apply this in practice so we
have a really interesting data set to
kind of experiment with
and hopefully that will be fun
so um let's dive into this
when i started looking into this
converse into this talk i
started looking to the definition of
metrics and to be fair as english isn't
my first language
it was a bit tricky for me to fully
understand what a metric is or the
difference between metric and distance
initially
but i think this definition from
wiktionary is actually a very good one
and that's basically a mean of deriving
a quantitative measurement or an
approximation for things that are
otherwise qualitative phenomena
and a couple of really let's say cool
standard metrics that we're talking
about is let's say this uh standard
meter from roughly
uh the 1800
and the standard kilogram which is
stored in in france
and you can think about let's say the
standard meter
right
as a quantitative way to
to measure how
far or
close things are
right so
if i'm trying to if i'm hungry for
cheesecake and i want to go to my
uh
late close um let's say cheesecake
bakery
uh i might be hungry and i feel like
it's far but my wife think it's near the
the meter
gives us an ability to actually quantify
how far is the cheesecake bakery from
from my home
[Music]
the thing is that distances
and sorry
um
so the
the difference between um
a metric and a distance
um
i think that they're quite synonyms so
metric is basically trying to to
estimate how similar or dissimilar
things are
and distances are really trying to to
measure the dissimilarity part so let's
say
uh for this uh
let's uh
yeah about this uh one second guys i
have a bit of a noise from my side
yeah so during this talk i'm going to
use distances and metrics
interchangeably um basically you can
think about other ways that we use
metrics in machine learning such as
let's say accuracy which basically tries
to measure how
close is a prediction from an actual
label
um
and i think in during this talk i'll
mainly start to focus on on the term
distance because i think distance is a
little bit more more intuitive
and
why distances and metrics are important
is
think about this way
if we would have had some sort of a
magic ball
that could quantify
for any two two samples
right whether they are semantically
similar or dissimilar
then a lot of the um let's say
core machine learning challenges that we
we know of today would be trivial so for
example think about classification
problems right so
if you had a perfect way to determine if
an image is more similar to a dog or a
cat
then given a new image i can tell you
whether this is a dog or a cat
if you had a perfect way to let's say
measure similarity between um let's say
songs or music
then
let's say based on my own personal
taste
i would be able to
[Music]
cluster and categorize and segment
different areas of music so that i could
know that well this segment of music i
like more this segment of music a lot
less and we build my own radio station
um recommendation system you know if i
could if i really enjoyed
um
a movie
if i could find a similar
uh movie to that right i'll be able to
stay engaged on your on your platform
um
and in general the
when you think about it right the the
power of this comes from the fact that
we have a lot of very good
distance based algorithms in machine
learning
so
k nearest neighbors k means this is a
couple of examples right
they're all working well provided that
the distances that you are measuring
are representative of the domain that
you are interested in
so
if we talk about so now i understand
let's say why
having a distance
that is a representative of the let's
say semantic similarity is important
let's try to dive into what exactly do
we do when we talk about metric learning
so in metric learning um
i took these definitions from wikipedia
so you can see that similarity learning
is an area of supervised machine
learning
[Music]
and that metric learning is the task of
basically learning a distance function
over object
so when i read this in the wikipedia
page i was asking myself two main
questions number one
why is learning a similarity
a supervised task
right i mean i don't know if i have
a cup and a bowl right like
i can just stay tell they are dissimilar
right like why is this
a a supervised task and the second one
that isn't coming too trivial to me is
what does it mean to learn the distance
and we will try to tackle both of these
questions
in this talk
by the way i see that in the chats there
are
some
some activities just uh make sure that
you're also reaching out to slack so
that i'll be able to to answer those
i see that one of them was on board
games so i hope this was fun
um all right so let's tackle the first
one right why is learning similarity a
supervised learning approach
so if we look into these three images
right we have i think
two images of barack obama and one
of
macron
and
basically
if we would try to let's say build a
system
that tries to verify
faces right so given a person
um is an another image of the same
person um belong to that person or not
like um
basically if i if i have a system of my
photos
and for someone else i wanted to say
that all the photos of mine are together
in one cluster let's say while photos of
someone else let's say my wife are in a
different cluster
then we would want to have a distance
function where let's say the distance
between this photo of obama and chrome
is greater than the distance between
this photo of obama and this photo of
obama
right
the thing is what happened if my task
isn't about trying to detect faces
but about trying to detect the rotation
of a face
i know suppose that
i
want
i have a crazy idea about
trying to
put
faces of individuals on top of iron man
suits and i have
different kind of models for iron man
that is rotated in its
angle and i want to know which one fits
uh
fits one i mean
i don't know why would anyone do that
but if we try to let's say detect uh the
rotation of a face right
then it could be that these
two faces would be
closer
than these two faces
and that's why
when you are talking about similarity
similarity in essence is a supervised
question
so based on the task that you are trying
to answer
you could try and learn
different kind of distances
um that would encapsulate the semantic
meaning that you're looking for
i will give it a
sense for a question in a second
i just wanted to dive a little bit into
the second question which is about
distances and learning the distances
so what exactly does distances mean
um
so if you go to um i think to look for
the mathematical definition of a
distance or a metric which you see they
use it interchangeably you see that it's
basically a mathematical function
that let's say given two
items
provides a number
and that function needs to satisfy these
certain rules so
number one is coincidence it's quite
straightforward so if we talk about the
distance from my house
to anywhere else is zero
then that anywhere else let's say that
anywhere else is x is my house
right
if we talk about cemeteries so the
distance between my house and the
cheesecake bakery is the same as the
distance between the 60 bakery in my
house
no negativity i can't have a negative
distance between my house and a
cheesecake bakery it just doesn't work
and the triangle in the quality so if i
want to get to my cheesecake bakery
i can't get faster
if i try to i don't know go through
um
through my supermarket first
if i try to go directly to the state
factory to this escape bakery that
should be the fastest
um and we already know of let's say
a couple of i think very well known
distances that you're you're familiar i
think euclidean distance is something
that i think most of us learn in junior
high
uh with the pythagoras
distance
uh sentence and the
the
manhattan distance
is uh quite reveal as well it's about
basically trying we caught the l1
distance in machine learning
and that's basically
the
absolute
the distance the absolute value of the
differences of the coordinates
so you can see those those couple of
examples here
um now these distances are are very well
known but
we can't really learn anything i mean
the distance between zero zero and four
three euclidean distance between them is
always five
right these are what's called
non-parametrized distances
but there are different set of distances
distances that come with parameters and
that we are able to actually learn these
parameters to better fit our problem
um and i think for our first question
that i'm asking you and then i'll have a
chance to look into the questions that
we had on slack
i have this question for you so there is
a parameterized distance that tries to
combine both the euclidean distance
when this parameter of this distance is
two
and the manhattan distance when this
parameter value is
one
do you know what it's called
i'm looking into the set as well yeah i
see vladimir uh already gave the the
right answer
uh
yeah
this is the the minkowski distance that
is correct
and this is an example for a
parameterized uh distance where you
provide one
parameter in this case that's p
and the distance is calculated in in the
following formula
um
it's uh you can see that basically when
p equals one then it just becomes the
difference in absolute value of the
coordinates
where the p is two
uh then it becomes the square root of
the uh
of the square value of the
the coordinates differences
so it could uh goods of vladimir so
maybe as a follow-up question the
minkowski distance is only defined for p
greater than one does anyone know why
yes exactly i think tom tom wrote that
as well it says a triangular inequality
and i see a erica also
answer that question um by the way uh uh
philip i
felipe asked about
the third definition that
the definition is certainly not fixed
here about the triangle inequality
um
sometimes there would be a cases where
intermediate point y would diminish the
distance between x and y
um
if so then that would not be a
a valid distance that would not
be considered a valid distance or a
metric
that's true that there are such
functions but vendor doesn't
constitute the metric
all right
um cool stuff and just so we can kind of
go to the notebook as well and of course
that my kernel restarted as uh
as we had this conversation
um
in uh and by the way let me know if you
can't see it i'll increase a bit the the
font size
great
um if you're interested in um
in trying out different distance metrics
then in sk learned neighbors um there is
this function over here
where you can try out you know how does
the occluding distance or the manhattan
distance that play out on different
points
um and
it even has the the minkowski distance
um and so in basically how does the
minkowski distance value change
uh for different p value
all right so now
i think we can dive into uh some more
interesting stuff because
here as we said there's only one
parameter that we can try to optimize
which is p
right
but
if we want to think about a
yeah see there is a old ask about link
to notebook it's in the yeah thanks
thanks jeremy
so if we talk about let's say
um
a different set of parameterized
distance matrices we have to talk about
this guy
where i think someone has already
answered
kranti
opposes if i mispronounce your name
kranti
already answered during the set
uh this is
prasanta
sandra mahalanobis
um
he is indeed
[Music]
one of the business associations in the
i think 1930s uh i think in india i did
the national statistics day was inspired
by him and he celebrated on his birthday
and he came out with
this unique
um it's a distance function
so if we look at
the euclidean distance which could be
written out
the following right where basically if
this is the center
then everything that's in this circle or
sorry that is on the border of the
circle has the same distance so the
distance from here to here it's the same
resistance from here to here
or the same existence from here to here
that's what's called the unit distance
well in the mahalanobis distance
he proposed putting a matrix over here
as a transformation
between those two um
those two differences of the vectors
and what's unique about this you can try
it out you know first try with the
identity matrix then
start sending the values there
um
you will see that what you find is that
there are different um
you could get to a transformation where
let's say the distance between here and
here
is the same as the distance between here
and here
and when you think about this
intuitively so
what mahanovi tried to do was he tried
to um basically
define what could be a distance between
a point and a distribution so if let's
say we find a point somewhere here
is this a part of this distribution or
not
and when in order to do that he set
m
to be
the inverse of the covariance matrix
now uh another bonus
yeah
another bonus question
um
there is another very common
unsupervised algorithm that uses the
inverse cover of the covariance matrix
does anyone know which one is it
svd
that's correct pca indeed that was the
the answer i was looking for
there is a very strong alignment between
uh pca and um and the major novice
distance uh i'll show this in a bit but
just so we can kind of showcase a little
bit how does the major novice distance
look like
so
in this code i basically draw an
ellipsoids and
and the figure so you can see it i
generate some
data set with let's say this is the the
mu and this is the scale
of those data
you can see it over here
so this is uh these are a set of
data points
from this distribution i also
added this point
and this point and what you see
uh i've generated two types of distances
so first the euclidean distance between
mu which is this this triangle and the
in-layer which is the square
so you see that the distance the
euclidean distance
from
this triangle to the square is much
bigger than the distance between the
triangle and the
um and the outlet
but
if you're taking this data and you're
trying to learn the mahadis distance
with the same
function
you find that actually the distance
between
this and the in layer
is much
less than the distance between this and
the outlier and what i drew here in
infusia
is basically the the
three unit distance so the distance
between here and here is three but also
the distance between here and here is
three
so you really have a chance to kind of
experiment and play around with this
again with this same mahada nobis
distance matrix
function
so you can try it out
um i'll dive in i'll saw in a second why
does it resemble pca but that's that's a
very good uh answer
okay
so we learned that basically um using
the uh inverse of a covariance matrix is
a good idea right it gives you a good
unsupervised approach
um but we talked about it that metric
learning is a supervised problem
and
we want to maybe learn a different kind
of an m that fits our problem
so um maybe this is a trickier question
do you know which kind of m's are
required for the metrics to be
well-defined
uh for the the distance metric to be
well-defined and i'll try to um to
assist
we said that every distance uh
symmetrical is a good idea but it's not
that we said that every um distance has
to be
uh non-nega
non-negative
right
so it can't be the uh to create a
distance that is negative
yeah exactly i think tom tom gets that
and i see a lot of people mention that
now as well marek and antonella
great
so indeed
there is this definition
which is called positive statement
definite which
quite literally means that
for every x vector
x transpose mx
is greater equals
zero this is literally the definition
now i don't know how much do you guys
remember your
metrics cookbook
um but for positive semi-definite uh if
you don't remember by the way there's a
link to this in in the notebook and page
51
there is this really cool uh
property for positive semi-definite
matrices that there is an invertible
matrix l such that l transpose l is m
so now
uh there's a bit of a math alert uh i
don't have my uh my horn with me
uh we're going to do
three lines of meth and solving so
we start with this which is the novice
distance between x and y
we're replacing m with this term over
here
we are uh saying the transpose of the
you know basically the the
transpose of the multipliers the
multiplier transpose so l goes inside
here and then we basically transpose the
entire thing
and
we're bringing l
inside of this parenthesis and also
inside of here
so bonus question can anyone try to
describe what this term is
yeah i think
cruz
said something
it is an l2 distance it is the l2
distance or the euclidean distance
between
yeah
sorry i'm losing my my screen yeah
it is the euclidean distance between
lx
and ly
and when i first saw that
i thought to myself
wow
this is beautiful right
because what what happened here right we
started by trying to learn
a distance
right we try to learn what is the end
let's say an m that is
a good fit for us
but
instead of learning a distance we are
learning a transformation
right a transformation where the
euclidean distance
makes sense
so
for the rest of the talk
right and and i think this is um
you should listen to uh to drake on this
one
instead of when you talk about metric
learning you talk about
what is the meaningful
you know you're trying to learn a
meaningful distance function in the
original space
what you are trying to learn here
is a meaningful transformation
so that the euclidean space or later
when we talk about this it could also be
the the cosine distance
or l1 distance but in this case right
you're learning a meaningful
transformation so the euclidean distance
is meaningful in the transformed
feature space
and i think that's
is inverse guaranteed that is part of
the definition of the
um
of the uh
positive semi-definite
indeed
all right so if we kind of go back to um
to the notebook i promised you that um
basically
the mahalanobis distance right so if we
saw that that's feasible for
for any matrix it's also feasible for
the um mahalanobis matrix
i see there is a very lively
conversation in the chat i'm minimizing
it for my attention but i'll i'll get
back to it in a second
um
so regarding the um
the transformation
so for those of you who's used a pca i
don't know how much you've noticed this
but there is a parameter called whiten
and the idea behind whitening of pca
is basically transform the signal into a
white noise but what it really does
is it basically
transform so if in pca you're
transforming your data
in a way that creates the most variance
what white and does is it transform your
data
with the l that is the l from the maha
nobis
matrix from the inverse covariance
matrix
and you can see it here in the i took
the same data set
and just applied basically
once the regular pca
um and once the they whitened the pca so
you see it here once with white and
false and once you fight them through
and you see that basically so this is if
we look again at our original
data
it was right here
so this was our original data set
right
after you do pca you get something like
this because you basically rotate the
accesses based on the most inverse
and after you do
whiten you get something like this so
you basically transformed
the um
the original data
to the space
where
this point is actually getting closer
than this one in the euclidean space and
to prove it to you right so if i do a
distance what is the distance in the
euclidean space
when white and is true
you get
the distance from the to the inlayer is
2.52
and the distance to the outlier
is
4.99 which is
exactly
the same distances that we saw in here
in the manual novice distance
so just to show you right that learning
a maha know this distance or learning
any kind of uh you know the distance
directly with the m is the same thing as
learning the transformation
any questions up to this point
yeah it is uh it is pretty awesome uh
thanks dennis it is quite cool
um
[Music]
so let's uh let's keep diving so indeed
when we talk now about
metric learning we understand that it's
not about learning a distance it's about
learning a transformation
and
you know when we talk about learning a
transformation
and you can go to metric learning from
all kind of directions so we took it you
know through the maha novice but you can
think about this also
from kernels or looking into other kind
of functions but
what we're really looking for is you
know given the original
feature representation of the data
how finding a new representation that is
easier to separate and that's what i
think you see here so you start with
let's say a mixed setup
you separate that
so that the new representation it's
easier to separate from a semantic point
of view
um
we just saw now a linear transformation
basically using l
but you know already know big data
neural nets uh you could also
do some nonlinear transformation as well
in my uh when i did my studies we did
this non-linear transformation with the
gradient boosted regressor trees as well
so this can work also with any
non-linear
function
function as well and there is this work
by uh i think
who works in microsoft he did an
excellent survey on different kind of
approaches
do check it out
i see the question do i understand
correctly that space transformation can
instead be represented as distance
function
a gain of inexplicability
um i think it's the other way around so
basically you know the the
the distance
is represented as
instead of
representing the distance
you are um you're learning in your
presentation where the euclidean
distance makes sense but do you wonder
if it's possible to do it the other way
around i don't know i need to think
about this and maybe talk to me in the
uh in the gather afterwards
yeah
let's talk about this afterwards
um
so
let's um let's understand in a second
what does this mean like
basically this
new representation because learning a
new representation sounds awfully like
manifold learning
so for those of you who are familiar
with manifold learning it's basically
you know trying to
reduce the dimensionality
but in a way that preserves the local
distances between
nodes so if let's say
you have in the higher dimensional space
this point close to this one
then in the lower dimensional space uh
these points will stay close
um
and indeed there is a little bit of a
similarity
um the the difference here is in the
supervision really so
by
i'm reducing the set again apologies for
my attention so the difference is in the
supervision
um
in
metric learning
you're learning you're using the
supervisor and you're using the
information you have about the classes
to learn this new dimens this uh lower
dimensional representation
so you're trying to learn a
representation let's say in this case of
uh of an algorithm that we'll dive into
in a second
uh you're learning so that a
representation that
these points
end up being closer together
well these points further away from from
this one uh where if you would use
manifold learning for this activity
all of these points will roughly be in
the same uh in the same place
and just to maybe kind of showcase
because i think umap has a very nice
demo
on the differences so umap is an uh
both manifold learning solution but they
have also a
metric learning solution and they apply
this on mnist
but the amnes fashion
which is basically 10 classes
same amount of instances but of fashion
which is a bit harder of a problem like
the difference between a certain
pullover isn't as clear as between a
seven and eight
um and what you see here is you really
see the difference between manifold
learning
and
distance metric learning
where
when you apply manifold learning similar
classes are still remaining similar
whereas when you do distance metric
learning there is a clear attempt to
separate
between those classes based on the
information that they're providing
we will solve this also in in the the
case that we're uh
or so casing
um
yeah so i think transformations are
often uh
optimized and evaluated on neighborhoods
and i think here we're starting to dive
a little bit into
how does the supervision
look like for
metric learning and in what way does it
differ from
um from classification because in
classification
you're basically having a function
that
generates a prediction a classification
or regression right it generates a
prediction
and then you are doing some sort of a a
loss
based on how do this prediction
differ from the expected value that
you've had
from the actual value basically
in metric learning
the output you get isn't a prediction
the output that you get is a new
representation of your data
and what you're trying to do
is you're trying to get a loss function
where
it represents
which of those uh instances are
let's say
instances that are closer together or
should be closer together
are they actually closer together and
instances that should be further apart
are they actually further apart
um let's dive into the uh the notebook
once more
just to kind of give you an example on
this um
actually before diving into this maybe
i'll go to this slide
the supervision when it comes to metric
learning can also be a little bit
different and sometimes we call it a
weekly supervised
than the regular class supervision so
of course you could use labels
basically you know for every instance
if they are the same label they need to
be closer together if they're distant
different labels they can be close
further apart
but
you could also give different types of
information it doesn't have to be
labeled that you in fact not all of your
data has to be fully labeled
so for example in this case right like
when we talk about tuples
um it usually comes in two sets so you
could have sets of points a and b where
a is similar to b
so i don't know uh king and queen
c k can tiramisu let's say no those need
to be close together in let's say a word
domain
where points that are further apart i
don't know
king and
boiler
right needs to be further away
you could also have triplets and that's
uh if you've ever heard of triplet loss
that's uh very common in this field of
metric learning where you basically pick
three points uh let's say
an anchor and then two other points that
one is supposed to be close and the
other one's supposed to be further away
so you can think about let's say king
that needs to be closer to queen then to
a toaster
right and then you can look into the the
embeddings of these words and
this will be the guidance you give it
and quadruplets um
that's something a bit less common but
still apparent where you give four
points where a is closer to b then c is
closer to d so stuff like king is closer
to queen
then
toaster is to
wife
um
yeah and then
now that we sort of understand that that
supervision doesn't certainly has to
come from labels but you can also come
from
different sources we can dive back into
this
into this notebook example
and to showcase i think one of the um
let's say
one of the loss functions that i like
the most and i think it's a
it's very resemblance to a different
loss function i'm going to show you
later
um
but uh i think stemmed a bit earlier
than that
and that's called the large margin
nearest neighbors i think it was uh
brought forth by weinberger and seoul in
2005.
um
when you look into uh
into this function it looks a little bit
like this
so
it has two parts
this first part right is
you are looking into
points that are have the same label or
should be in the same neighborhood
and you're distancing you're penalizing
on the distance between them so
basically if two points needs to be
neighbors of each other
but they are further away let's say the
distance is three then you're finalizing
um
the square distance which is let's say
nine
so
that
encourages the algorithm to learn an l
that brings those target neighbors
closer together
the second part of that loss function is
um
if there is an imposter like let's say
an entity that shouldn't be a part of
the neighbor
of the neighborhood so if that
instance is closer to my anchor
than uh
than the
the j than than the actual neighbor that
i need to have
within some sort of large margin and
this one here doesn't matter that's much
because l it can always scale so yes you
just put one here and then
l learns a transformation
um
what it does it basically it penalizes
for imposters within the neighborhoods
so
if you're looking let's say at this
right the same transformation that we've
just shown
it will learn an l so that the
mahalanobis distance looks like this
so basically tries to find all of these
instances um
that are similar to make them closer
while these instances are further away
further apart
um and you can see basically that when
you analyze this function you see a
couple of things right you see that in
this case the transformation is linear
you could have used something that is
non-linear
the space that the latent space they're
using here is euclidean so basically
we're trying to optimize the euclidean
distance between them
the objective function as i said
composed of pulling
pushing and then some sort of trade-off
by default the trade-off is the same
it's 0.5 between those two terms
though you can best learn it with
cross-validation as
well um
the reason why i'm detailing this and by
the way there are a lot of really really
cool um
i'd say metric learning uh approaches
when you read metric learning papers
it's always about trying to find new
ways of representing
similarity within the neighborhood like
neighborhood component analysis
um does some sort of a soft max and
trying to improve the accuracy that your
nearest neighbor is actually
um the one from the same label
itml uses
information theory topics
uh this paper is actually done written
by
ai celebrities
like andrew ing michael jordan uh it's a
really cool read and i think one of the
first ones in in this field
uh that really introduces this uh topic
of uh different symmetric learning uh so
if you have some time and you're looking
to see some historical uh
you know instead of looking at the
michael jordan basketball game from the
90s you want to
to read the mic absorbent paper from
2003 uh you can find it here
and um the reason why i'm kind of diving
into those because as you will try
yourself
to read a little bit more on to these
loss functions
you will see that here you will see lots
of different loss functions right
but every time you read a loss function
you will find basically similar
activities like you will find
um what is the distance that they are
using here
um are they using let's say triplets or
or pairs
um and what is the distance they end up
using
so
basically these concepts of
understanding the output distance
understanding how does the supervision
look like
um and understand the objective
like in this case i think it's it's
really similar to what we are just
saying right the distance between
the positive points uh
needs to be small and the distance
between the negative points needs to be
large
um so understanding this as a as a
concept i think is a good baseline for
you to dive into
um
okay i think i talked enough i think i'm
ready to show you some some cool
examples and code but first i want to
see if there are any more questions so
let me look into the slack i don't see
any questions on slack
let's see questions on the
uh
let's see let's see let's see let's see
how okay let's start with um
see a lot of uh questions so um
tsme um they're actually uh different
approaches but uh you could use both of
them
both of them are uh
are useful techniques for
manifold learning and i think this paper
really
this publication really nicely showcase
the difference between them do check it
out
how is the neighborhood defined good
question it's a parameter so it's
something that you could also learn in
your uh
either learn or provide yourself depends
on how
let's say
how do you want to represent your data
uh we will showcase i think uh a couple
of examples where we'll have different
case and that translates to different
sizes of
of neighborhoods
let's see you still need a definition
definition of what
i'm sorry i'm sorry i got lost here when
one wish to use triplet distance are we
talking about supervised problems right
so in metric learning they're all
supervised uh information
right it's just that the
information that we are
providing is coming in the form of uh
triplets so you can think about it this
way right let's say that you have a
label
right like let's go back to the um to
this
data set that we've had
okay
um and you have these two images of a
sneaker
right
you can create a triplet supervision by
saying well this sneaker
needs to be closer to this sneaker
than to this coat
that creates basically a triplet uh
representation of your supervision
does that does that help to to clarify
oh how do we decide in neighborhood good
question so
if we say that our neighborhood let's
say composers or there are two ways of
doing this right one is you can specify
a distance you can say that anything
that is within let's say 0.1 is in my
neighborhood
another which is i think a more natural
way of doing this is to look into your k
nearest neighbors
so
if you have um let's say
within your five neighbors
uh peop neighbors of the same label so
let's say all of yours
for this instance all of its neighbors
are sneakers
then that's great but if in your
neighborhood you have coats and ankle
boots and sandals um
then that that isn't so good right
so
the the loss function
right
is determined by this k right like uh
based on the um
based on defining
who in your neighborhood is uh sorry
how many instances are in your
neighborhood i think you we will saw
this a bit in the code example so you
can dive a little bit into this later on
but if i didn't answer you let me let me
know
there was an advocate how does this
relate to gun
it is a form of representations learning
representation learning
definitely it's not trying to i guess
reconstruct it
but
i think in this context we are actually
mo i think in gun you're
it relates quite heavily but i think in
this context we are
looking for
the representation itself rather than
let's say the output of that
of that network so i think in gun it's
more important to
to look into the transformation function
here you're mainly focusing on the
output representation
but we can uh we can have that
conversation i think also
in the
in the gamertown as well or in slack
but but they are quite related they're
both forms of representation learning
um cool ready to see some some fun fun
code
do people do classification on top of
the learn metric like kanye in his
neighbor or cluster
yes yes you can definitely
do that in fact in this
new representation
um
the idea is that
you have a lower dimension
that represents your data in a manner
that
doing this sort of classification
clustering k-nearest neighbors is much
more simple and much more intuitive
um but we will show this
i think in a second
so let me show you a little bit on the
uh
of code
i see more questions uh maybe last one
before we dive
how do you evaluate something like on
this on a holdout set it seems any
learned metric here would be entirely
based on the data you have in hand um
quite simply actually i didn't do it in
this demo but
the way you do this is by
taking let's say a um
actually we saw this on the test set
yeah we do have tested so
stay with me
but if you're asking about the
validation
you can take let's say validation
instance and then evaluate that
you take the training points as your
reference
and you will check whether let's say
your test points after a transformation
are close to known uh training points
but we will solve this
i think this will be cool i am muting
the set again i'll be back to it in a
second
all right so let's dive
into this
data set which i found to be really cool
um
it's a data set called banking 77 it was
made available by
inigo casa nueva
tadas
daniela
mateo henderson and ilan vulis and i
apologize if i butchered any of them
their names
[Music]
but it's uh it is a very fun data set it
comprises of 13 000 customer service
queries
labeled into 77 intents
[Music]
in the banking domain so
you can load this data from here um
they made this available
and you can see a couple of examples so
they have i think about 10 000
training instances and about 3 000 test
instances and you can see that you have
let's say a category that is change pin
and then there is the text associated
like is it possible to for me to change
my p
top of failed
quite clear i think in in the banking
domain it's quite relatable and i think
you will be able to understand what what
happens here
um
to make this problem a bit more feasible
also for for your notebook
um
i am reducing the number of training
points that i'm going to use so i'm only
using 10 training points only 10
from each of the 77 classes so in total
we will have
770 training points but i'm not touching
the test so i'll still use all the tests
for for evaluation purposes
uh in their paper by the way they also
showcase results for if you take 10
classes from its 30 classes from each or
if you use all the the data set all
right so we started from raw text
[Music]
and the first thing we need to do i
think before we start with any metric
learning
is we're going to have to start
um
representing this in some sort of a
vector right um
now
this talk isn't about sentence embedding
but if you're interested in this problem
you have links in this
notebook as well
and you know as a simple data scientist
what i'm trying to do you know i'm
trying to get to a good representation
i'm looking into well what are the let's
say
best supported models right sorry these
are all the transformation models let's
say i look into the evaluation
they have this really nice uh excel or
google seats
um
seeing wow okay this looks like it's the
best sentence embedding that they have
at the moment
so
this is what i'm taking
um
and it's quite straightforward you
basically load the sentence transformer
on this device
if you are running this by the way um
you know this encoding on a cpu it might
take about
four to eight minutes on zip use it
travel fast
um
and what we get ultimately is this kind
of set so we have
a training set which has 768
[Music]
features
um the class associated with each of
those points and then we have the test
set right which is the full data set
also with this uh embedding model
and the
3d thousand labels
next
let's start evaluating these
these embeddings
um
there will be two ways for that we will
evaluate the embeddings and i want to
kind of showcase the uh both of them the
first one is a visual one which i find
to be quite cool and for that i use a
library called altair
it's i think the way they described it
is
a descriptive
visual um
interactive visual
component on top of
notebooks um
it's really quite easy
so if you're looking for something
interactive on notebooks do check it out
um
i would say i think the i think they put
the links on it in the in the notebook
as well um the idea behind the one
another thing that i like which also
saves me right now because my kernel
died
um is that
they actually embed these uh visuals
within the um
within the notebooks themselves so it's
uh remain available for you even if you
don't have a kernel
and what i do here is i basically take
these embeddings that
that we learned from the sentence
embedding
and doing a pca transformation on that
and what we see is this
very very colorful image
that really doesn't tell you much and
the reason why it doesn't tell you much
is because
it's uh it's pca
that's exactly um
the reason why you sometimes want to use
manifold learning because
pca isn't a good technique to um to
visualize the relationship in a very
high dimensional space
so what you want to do yeah thanks uh
thanks alan rosa
she put on the slack the the link to
alter
what you want to do right in this setup
is to actually do something like tsne or
umap so that you'll be able to see the
the relationship between the instances
in the higher dimensional space
so that's what we do
and by the way in i think tsne
in scikit-learn
one
there is a new function which is
learning great auto which i think is a
better representation of the data
so what we do here
is we took the query we did sentence
embedding
and then we did tsme and now we can see
some things
okay now what do we see here
we see a couple of
let's say categories that are very well
separated by the
general language model
like for example edit personal detail
right i put here both the testing and
the training points so you can see them
[Music]
and we see that let's say some instances
are a bit uh let's say
closer like i know changing pins is
close to
getting physical card
which needs to be activated by pin or
pin blocked right
or this one which is a little bit a
little bit all over the place like why
verify identity
verify my identity
and unable to verify identity
and we also see some that are a bit
more of a mess
right but it's a good place to start i
mean if you think about um
let's say what we will try to do now is
to get a bit more of a cool
we saw a qualitative estimation now
we'll do a quantitative one
um
and we will use two measurements here
both the accuracy we will do kenya's
neighborhood accuracy but we'll also use
the mean average precision r which is i
think written by the same person that
made this
this library available his name is kevin
musgrave
again apologies kevin if i if i'm
booster in your name but i really
appreciate the work you guys have you've
been doing
um
and what i want to show here is
basically
an example on how um how does this
parameter evaluated right so
basically if you have 10 results but
only the first one is correct then
that's good but if you have let's say
only the first and the tenth is correct
uh it means less whether if let's say
the first and the second neighbor is
correct so what we're going to do is
we're going to rank
all of the neighbors for each point and
then we'll see if whether this
neighbor
the first the second the third the
fourth
um are that same um
[Music]
of that same label basically
let's go back to here
and what we see here in that baseline
is that we actually have a decent
accuracy uh which is you know kudos to
the the language model right to the
sentence embedding and and bert
um
i see someone had an import error um i
mentioned that in the
in the slack uh beforehand just restart
the kernel yeah thanks uh thanks claudia
um
so
um what you see here is basically the
accuracy is quite decent um still not at
the level that the paper is is reaching
to
but let's say the neighborhood itself
right as you especially as you grow to
higher neighborhoods you have much less
precision yeah
okay
um
[Music]
so now
let's do some metric learning
so we sold large margin nearest neighbor
there is this library here called metric
learn which already implements quite a
lot of these metric
learning functions
and you can
you can experiment and learn read a
little bit more about the different
offerings that this library already has
but it's quite straightforward so you
put large margin nearest neighbor you
put here number of components so
basically that will be the output
dimension that you would want for um
for your transformation so in this case
we will learn a
768
over
192 matrix
you specify k equals 5 in this case so
basically when you are evaluating the
neighborhoods always look into your five
uh k nearest neighbors
um
and you do fit
and frankly you know like if
if i'm thinking about my talk
this would have been it right like this
these four lines that's what you need to
do for for metric learning
uh i specified here variables true so we
can
see what happens here so basically
this is the objective function of the
element n
and this one is the active constraint so
basically how many imposters are within
the neighborhood
and what you see is that as it learns
the number of imposters keeps going down
so he's able to find a
representation where those neighborhoods
become
less and less corrupted
and more homogeneous
ultimately
you can know you can just do transform
of that
original data set
and then you get
both a much better accuracy and we
evaluated it for different k values 1 3
5 7 9
but also much better um
let's say neighborhoods and when you
look into the
the output visually
it's a bit tricky but let me try to put
this like this
and maybe
of course it doesn't
i'll try to put them side by side so
you'll be able to see this uh
this comparison
but i think you will see that this one
is a much cleaner representation or a
much
clearer transformation
yeah so that was the the original one
and there you see you're really able to
to address some of those let's say more
wacky
and noisy
transformations and breaking them down
into classes
um
yeah another thing that i think
worth to kind of showcase right
especially with this tool right is like
how easy it is to to explore and
evaluate your uh your data sets right so
um like if this is let's say a visa or
mastercard
and this is a wrong labeled
identification yeah this is actually
a true false negative but i want to show
a couple
like this one
this is about cancel transaction this is
a cluster on cancel transactions
and then you have this one which is
request refund how do i cancel previous
purchase
which to be fair is very very close to
cancel transaction
right
how do i cancel my order so
it actually you know
is able to to take into account also
proximity of classes in in this
representation
um
and again maybe one last point right we
didn't use a lot of data
we only use 10 class 10 points
for every class
um
and still you know what we were able to
find a meaningful representation
maybe one last point that i wanted to
mention uh before diving into the deep
learning one
[Music]
is about the dimensionality reduction
so we reduced the dimensionality from
768 dimensions to 192 about a quarter
and now frankly this is just a magic
number
you would probably want to do a
validation and to evaluate if that is
sufficient for you
um
but the the guiding principle here is
that
the
768 dimensions
that was
to encapsulate the the wider general um
[Music]
you know language model right for
all kind of texts in the entire world
but in our case we're really just trying
to learn a specific problem
which was um
trying to
cut to categorize and classify
um customer service queries to maybe
later chatbot to to answer those
questions
and that's why
using a lower dimension makes a lot of
sense um and again looking into what is
the actual value that works for you is
something for you to
to dive into
um for the last part of this tutorial
and maybe let's see if there's any
questions or you know what i'll go
through the last one because i want to
make sure that people who wants to try
out also with deep metric learning will
be able to do so and then i'll use the
rest of the time for questions
um
so you as i said you can't really do
metric learning without uh
without deep learning right and it's
it's the biggest thing now
um there is this really great library
again that kevin uh
made available and you can read about
this in the library website
i'm not going to dive into here i use
tensorflow sorry i use pytorch
i'm not going to to give a tutorial
about building a
deep learning model in python but i will
highlight a couple of differences with
respect to
what are the things that we are
specifying in order to make this uh to
make this work
um
first regarding the model so the model
looks
i think similar to other kind of deep
learning models that you will sew
so it's basically let's say
a hidden layer here
then another hidden layer
but the output instead of let's say
uh outputting it with one activation
function which is let's say
the regression result or
the class that that we're trying to to
learn
um
it's actually just another one of those
uh linear representation or basically
we're trying to
optimize this
192
features
uh and that will be the the output
representation for us
um
this is the the full model there is
nothing nothing more to it
um
we need to specify here
a couple of uh
functions so
as i said what is the distance that
we're going to to use to evaluate the
um let's say the differences between the
the
embeddings um
what is the
uh the loss function so in this case i'm
using a
construct
contrastive loss
which we showcased also before
and what is the mining function which
basically helps me to find out
um
which are the neighbors that i'm every
time going to evaluate so i think in
this case in an angular minor is trying
to find out neighbors that are
similar in angle or
i think you can see it in
i open again that
library website
and what's really nice about the work
that kevin has done here
that when you look into the losses
it really details you what is the setup
that it works so you know what is the
reducer that uh that he's using
uh what kind of
sorry
um what is the input for that reducer
and how do you um you know
how do you create a fit that actually
makes this uh this workplace if you're
using the lp distance or or the crossing
distance
um in this case i i chose the
the l2 distance and
the same kind of output dimension just
because i wanted to compare this with
the
linear
transformation
but you can play around with these
settings as well as well with this this
model
and the last point that i think
is a little bit different
is these parts
so usually what you do when you're
training every every epoch you are
putting your data in labels you're doing
optima zero grad
um but this one is a little bit uh
unique
in a sense that first you're creating
your embeddings
you basically apply your model on your
data to create get a new transformation
you are using the mining functions to
learn basically uh the tuples so which
of the instances need to be close to
each other and which ones to be further
away
and then you feed this into the loss
function
and that's the thing that you're
doing a backward and an optimization
step
that's really the core of it and there
is i think some some good example code
in um
in the
uh the library
information
um what you see here is basically the
loss keeps going down
and
ultimately right you're
getting the same embeddings by
applying the deep metric learning on the
data set
and then you're using those embeddings
in the same way that we've done here so
we're basically evaluating the
mean average per season at r and
evaluating their accuracy
and using the same information the same
information to visualize this
now
what i found interesting
looking into the output from the deep
learning one
is that you see it's much more separable
than the
um than the linear one and part of it is
because when you're applying non-linear
transformation it's much easier to kind
of
separate your data
uh it doesn't necessarily has to
translate to better performance but in
this case it is and like i said the way
that you would probably want to build
this is with a proper validation set uh
and making sure that let's see you find
the hyper parameters that optimize uh
that optimize the
[Music]
let's say the error that you are looking
at
so if i just go back again to the the
original objectives that i had for the
talk
we learned a little bit about
metrics distance functions and metric
learning
i think we saw what it means to learn a
distance and then we completely forgot
about that and
instead of that we decided to learn a
transformation
we saw the relationship between metric
learning and manifold learning
we got a chance to dive into some loss
functions and understand that basically
we're evaluating the representation
and we saw a really really cool
data set sets
and seeing you know how do you actually
apply this in practice to
to learn about segments in your um in
your answers
and i hope you guys had fun too
so i think with that we have some time
for questions
yeah customers are might stagger indeed
right that that's because it's easier to
separate
um when you when you look into um the
definition of the contrastive loss
you can also specify here
what is the positive margin and what is
the negative margin so if you want let's
say
to be more tight you make this really
really close to zero if you want to make
this spread a bit wider you increase
that positive margin
uh
is it safe to say that the nice results
on here are due to fairly clean data
i don't know i don't think so uh what i
was trying to showcase actually
is that there is quite a lot of overlap
between the uh between the classes
themselves right so if i
go again to the
maybe here
right
uh maybe before the the
the actual transformation
right this is how it started after
using the state-of-the-art sentence
embedding right sentence embedding
sentence transformer siamese birth
and even there right you see like
i know disposable card limits
disposable virtual cards
get virtual cards virtual card not
working right these these classes are
really really um
close together
uh and there is quite a lot of also uh
mislabeled information that's what i was
sort of trying to to showcase as well
right
so i can't say it's it's all just um
let's say due to clean data
i think uh part of it is really about
let's say the approach as well
[Music]
let's see more questions
if we apply our model to new set of
customer service text without labels can
we expect to see new clusters for new
previously unknown classes
i believe so right like uh what we've
done what we're doing in our uh
work setting we're using this
actually on company's behavior
trying to detect new types of companies
behaviors and seeing how they differ
from each other
one thing i didn't mention but
one key strength of this approach is
that it works with
very few labeled instances as well so if
you let's say only have
i don't know
a hundred points labeled out of a
database of a ten thousand
um especially when you do linear
transformation
it generalizes really well
um
yeah i see there are questions on the
slack channel as well um
can you explain why n components is 192
what happens if n component is two and
visually visualize directly
um very very good question and nicola
by the way i'll go to the slack
questions in a second
so what we've done in the
i'm not sure what it will do in the
non-linear one
but i know what it will do in the linear
one and that it will give you something
similar to this
and the reason is that
finding a linear transformation
that shows that representation
and that we've seen to a two-dimensional
space directly
is really infeasible all right so
the the reason why tsme was able to kind
of identify those neighborhoods is
because when they transform
they're using a non-linear transform a
non-linear dimensionality reduction
approach
[Music]
and if you're in a sense pca right it's
also a linear transformation right it
just tries to maximize over the variance
um so you will get something similar to
this
um
i i don't i don't think i tried
doing this directly on the
two-dimensional space
um
my suspicion is that it's going to be
still noisy
because
but but you know try it try it out
definitely in the deep one let's say in
the linear one i can tell you already
it's just going to to translate to this
thing
um let's see
what are the rules for reducers and
miners
okay
so miners as i said right it's really
about trying to find out um
how do you create these sort of uh
tuples based on the
functions that you're looking so how do
you create pairs how do you create
triplets how do you create
quadruplets
reducers i think it's about taking all
of these
losses
from each individual um
it's indivisible our output
and generate one loss function so
basically you are creating
if we look at um let's say again one of
those losses like the contract loss
if you're looking into this loss right
so this loss is defined per every anchor
point
and
i think the the reducer what it does is
just basically aggregates them all
together to in this case an average one
an average non-zero reducer so things
are let's say
if they are zero they don't count into
the uh the average
um but i think this flow should make it
a bit clearer right so
i hope that answers the question uh
victor
[Music]
let's see
i wonder if you could use this for
unsupervised outlier detection
um well um
we talked about this uh uh
before right when we talked about the
maha-nobis distance that this is an
unsupervised uh
learning approach in a sense you got um
you know you you came to metric learning
talk and you got an outlier detection
technique for free so that that's value
for money
um
but
i think that in order as i said to to do
this um
[Music]
let me just go back to to the pca
whitening
yeah this one
um
this is really helpful for let's say
outlier detection right like this is
something that can really you know you
just look into the distance between the
the mean
and then that helps you to to detect
outliers
but the the metric learning itself
requires some sort of supervision and
again it doesn't have to be full
supervision it could be weak supervision
it could be parcel supervision even it
doesn't have to be for all the points
how many people label
triplets in practice um
you can think about this
you can think about this sometimes as
you know part of the data engineering
activities that you do like um
so number one you
the fact that a loss function
is defined by triplets doesn't mean that
it has to
your data has to be triplets uh we just
saw it in this example right where our
data were classes and then we were able
to
apply a triplet function on it
the second point is that
you can think about it sometimes like if
you are netflix right
and you see
how many minutes someone uh
you know spent on on a specific uh show
and you can say well you know like
this so is closer to a different so that
another person spent a lot of time off
as opposed to
this um other this third show that he he
watched this one episode and didn't uh
find interesting at all
so it's really about you know how is it
represented in in the world
but i think that um
it's think about it more of a
flexibility point rather than as a
limited factor
right so if
if the your data is such that this is
the kind of supervision you have that's
great uh otherwise you can use the
label
thanks uh thanks luis i appreciate that
[Music]
thanks uh thank you y'all as well i i
like your talk as well
uh
can we talk about multi-modal case
interesting
um
there are
different ways of kind of generalizing
this uh
this activity as well so
if you read the literature you could
find what they called
locally linear metric learning so
basically you're trying to learn
different transformations for different
areas of the space
that is actually
something that
is useful so you first try to split your
space and then learn different
transformations on on each area
[Music]
sometimes you try to do
[Music]
a linear
transformation and then
go non-linear to kind of build on top of
those similarities that you've already
done
but frankly in most of the applications
that i i see recently like you know the
deep learning ones
they're just trying to directly uh do
this this sort of learning
all right uh i think
we can wrap it up so as uh mentioned
before i'm going now to
the uh where is it
uh yeah
i'm going to the government to keep
having this conversation if anyone's
interested in following up
[Music]
it can be about metric learning and it's
application it could be about banking
i.t it could be about board games i'll
be very happy to get more
recommendations my wife and i have a
collection of i think 250 of them
so
your advice would slowly be appreciated
and looking forward to seeing you again
in person next time